hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
believe it or not
a lefty said something sensible
madam president
uh
i want to take a moment to say a few
words
about the so-called inflation reduction
act that we are debating
uh this evening
and i say so-called by the way because
according to the cbo
and other economic organizations who
have studied this bill
it will in fact have a minimal
impact on inflation
madam president
let me put this
reconciliation bill
into the context of where we are
as a nation
politically and economically
and the answer to that as to where we
are is
we are not in
a good place
according to the most recent gallup poll
the approval rate for congress
is at 16
with 82 percent of the american people
disapproving of the work
we are doing here 16 think we're doing a
good job
82 percent think not
further according to a recent university
of chicago poll
a strong majority of americans and this
is extremely important and i hope
members of congress hear this
a majority of americans believe that the
government is quote
corrupt
and rigged against me end of quote
people believe the government is corrupt
and rigged against them
further according to a usa today poll
that came out last week
a very strong majority no longer believe
that the democratic or republican
parties
are responding to their needs
and we need to move to a multi-party
system
and i think what is most frightening in
terms of where the american people are
politically today
is that there is actually a growing
number of americans
who believe that they may have to take
up arms
take up arms
against their own government
in order to accomplish what they think
needs to be done
madam president all of this speaks to a
very very dangerous moment
for american democracy
and in a number of ways it resembles the
conditions
that existed in europe in the 1920s
and early 1930s
which led to fascism
and totalitarianism
in other words
at a time when so many of our people are
hurting
many of them no longer believe that in
our democratic system
government is capable of responding
to their needs
and they are losing faith
in our democracy
the people of this country believe
and in my view correctly
that we have a corrupt political system
dominated by the wealthy
and the powerful
and that we have a rigged economy
in which large corporations are seeing
huge profits some cases
heaviest profits ever while the middle
class
and working families
continue to see a decline in their
standard of living